[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDREW BROGDON: Hey, everybody.
We're back and we're here
with Eric Seidel, one
of the leaders for
the Flutter project,
one of the founders
of the project,
here to answer some questions.
And I have a few [INAUDIBLE]
questions already.
Wm is still taking a
look at the stream.
And so let's start off.
Can you tell us
a little bit more
about the Flutter origin story?
Because I've told it to people,
Flutter started as a quest
for speed, and I'd love to
know that I'm not lying.
ERIC SEIDEL: No,
that's totally right.
Flutter did start as
a quest for speed.
So Flutter, in its very
earliest incarnation,
was just a very cut
down version of Chrome.
We took Chrome and we
just allowed ourselves
to break compatibility with the
web and chop out lots of stuff
and see how fast
we can make it go.
ANDREW BROGDON: Things
that were in there
for older standards,
compatibility
with older things?
ERIC SEIDEL: Just
all sorts of things.
The thing that we built wasn't
able to render any web pages,
but it could run our benchmarks.
And when we ran our benchmarks,
they were 20 times faster,
and so we knew we
had something there.
ANDREW BROGDON: So you
had a rendering engine
and then I've
heard that was sort
of a search for a
language at that point.
Can you tell us about that?
At one point, Flutter was
written in JavaScript,
is that right?
ERIC SEIDEL: That's right.
So we actually went
through several iterations.
We did have a rendering engine.
It was all in C++ originally,
and then we started writing
more and more JavaScript code.
Eventually, we had some trouble
with the JavaScript code
and so we went searching for
another language, and then,
eventually, all the C++
died away, or most of it.
And once we found Dart, and
that worked so well for us,
we just wrote more and
more and more Dart code.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, cool.
And where did Flutter,
the name, come from?
I saw that in the
stream earlier.
Where did the name
Flutter come from?
WM LELER: And we've actually
heard this story before,
but it's so good, we
have to hear it again.
ERIC SEIDEL: So it turns
out, naming is really hard.
So we did these things called
trademark searches, where
you make sure that you can use
the name in various countries,
and all that.
And they're not cheap and
they take a long time.
And we did a bunch
of them and we
didn't find any names that
we liked that you could use.
And so we got a
little desperate.
But it turns out that
Google has a cache of names
from companies that they
bought and they're not using.
ANDREW BROGDON: Previously
acquired companies.
ERIC SEIDEL: Yeah, or
they turned down a name,
for whatever reason.
And that's where
Flutter came from.
It was a small startup
that they had bought.
And the product had turned down
but the name was still there,
and that's how we
ended up being Flutter.
WM LELER: That is wild.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right,
we've got another question here.
This one comes from Twitter.
The account is [INAUDIBLE]
from [INAUDIBLE] in Romania.
So [SPEAKING ROMANIAN].
Can you talk a little bit
about the evolution of Dart
and how Flutter
influenced, perhaps,
some of the features
that were in Dart 2.0?
So were there things that
Flutter needed from Dart
that the Dart team then
came back and said,
yeah, we can put those
in the language for you.
ERIC SEIDEL: Oh, totally.
There's so much
that's been added
to Dart in the last
few years, specifically
for Flutter, the trailing
comments for the formatting,
the [? intadouble, ?] the
EOT support, in general.
That was a huge
feature that was done
by the Dart team for Flutter.
Lots of Flutter-specific
performance enhancements.
Yeah, just lots and lots of work
that's gone into Dart to make
Flutter an awesome.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Let's see.
So this one comes
also from Twitter.
This is from Tara
[? Fuelles ?] 30.
Will Google introduce a
Flutter certification program,
similar to ones that
exist for Android?
ERIC SEIDEL: So I've
heard that there
are these other
certification programs
for the other products,
which is awesome.
I think that those are
things that we would think
about a little bit later on.
I mean, we just hit 1.0 today.
So I think it's a
good idea, but I
think that's probably going
to take a little while.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Cool.
And this is one last one,
sort of a general question
for a lot of people watching.
How can someone looking
to contribute to Flutter
best make an impact?
So if you're watching
this and you're like,
I really like Flutter.
I like this community.
I would like to be part
of it as a contributor.
What are some of the
best ways to do that?
WM LELER: Other than the fact
that you're hiring, right?
ERIC SEIDEL: And it's true.
We are always hiring.
We have tons of open positions.
To contribute to
Flutter, so we do
have a bunch of documentation
on GitHub about exactly this.
And there are lots
of ways to contribute
beyond just human engineering.
There's tons of triage to do.
All these people who
are running events today
in support of Flutter.
That's contributing
to the system, right?
So yeah, there's lots of
engineering-specific tasks
that are listed on GitHub.
Bugs are fixed.
We even have an easy fix
label, helping with early bugs.
There's these contributing
docs on both the engine side,
for those who like C++, as well
as the Flutter framework side,
for those who like Dart.
There's lots of docs up on
GitHub about exactly this.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK, great.
Yeah.
And of course, we have
the package ecosystem,
and all sorts of stuff, right?
ERIC SEIDEL: Exactly.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Excellent.
So that's about all
of our time, I think.
Do we have any other
questions for Eric
that we wanted to touch on?
WM LELER: That's all the
questions I wanted to ask.
ANDREW BROGDON: We've
pretty much run out of time.
Thank you so much for
joining us and talking
to everybody on our screen, and
enjoy the rest of Flutter Live.
ERIC SEIDEL: Thanks
for inviting me.
WM LELER: [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BROGDON: You
can take that with you
and exit right out there.
Thank you so much.
That was cool.
WM LELER: Well, I've got
a couple of questions.
ANDREW BROGDON: What
else do we have?
WM LELER: Well, let
me ask this one.
This is a question.
It says, "can we
design and develop
apps for e-commerce
businesses with Flutter?
This is one of those
questions where
I didn't have to pay the person
to ask this, but I would have.
ANDREW BROGDON: The answer is
people are already doing it,
right?
WM LELER: That's right.
ANDREW BROGDON:
You know Alibaba.
WM LELER: Yeah, Alibaba
is one of the largest
e-commerce companies
in the world
and they're using
Flutter for their app.
ANDREW BROGDON: Absolutely.
We have a sample [INAUDIBLE].
WM LELER: That's right.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: Can we see that?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yes.
If you watched the keynote, you
already saw it a little bit.
Let me go ahead and pull up--
WM LELER: That's right.
When Will got up and talked
about Material Design.
ANDREW BROGDON: Let me get
this zoomed in so everybody
can see it.
WM LELER: And it has
e-commerce app built into it.
ANDREW BROGDON: The Material
team built several samples
to show off what Material could
do, the new stuff launching
IOAT and how well you can
put it to work in Flutter.
And one of their
demos is Shrine,
which is a shopping app.
And so we took the work that
they did and we're like,
hey, let's put a little
state management into this.
And we made a new
scoped_model with it
and put a shopping
cart into it and put it
on the DevRel samples repo.
So it's up at flutter/samples,
samples, so look for Shrine
and you could download
that right now.
And if we go to my
left-- here we go.
Gradle's just about done.
This is an example
of an e-commerce app.
So I could just click
through Next here.
You get right on.
So we have a list of products,
just like you would expect.
I think Will is himself.
Yes, he is in here
himself as a model.
Because we needed
a model that day,
I guess, for the photos team.
And so you can click
on things and add them
to your shopping cart.
And you can see the
Material team, of course,
has put a lot of time into this.
The expanding bottom
sheet, for the preview
of what's in the
cart, I know they're
very proud of because
it looks so cool.
But you can add
things just like that.
I can click on the bottom sheets
and it expands into the carts.
I can come in here and
take things out of it.
There's a model, managing the
state of what's in the cart,
tallying up things.
But yeah, obviously,
e-commerce is a huge sector
of the mobile app ecosystem.
It's very important.
So certainly, Flutter,
the team had that mind
as they were building
everything out for Flutter.
Yeah, works great.
What else we got?
WM LELER: I've got
some live questions.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
WM LELER: Let me pick one.
Is there a way to
embed native UI?
And the example they use, can
I put Apple Pay into an app
and have a Flutter button
that invokes Apple Pay?
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
Yeah, we can talk a
little bit about that.
So the Google Maps
plugin, you already
saw that Phil had demonstrated.
That's using under the hood
something called PlatformView.
And so PlatformView,
there is an Android view.
And there's a UIKit view.
And these are the widgets
that sort of manage
a platform, a
native PlatformView,
and fit it into the
world of Flutter.
And so those are available.
You could do it and try
them out on your view
and see how that goes.
There's a bit of a
cost to the work they
have to do under the
hood, so I wouldn't just
start throwing 30 of them
into every Flutter screen
that you have that.
That wouldn't be a
good implementation.
But if you have one specific
view that you really
need to have, like a
control that you've
invested a lot of
time in building,
or something for the
platform, you really
need a particular piece
of the platform live,
those have been
added now and you
can start putting them to
work in your Flutter apps,
PlatformViews.
WM LELER: I have
another question.
This is from Seattle.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh.
WM LELER: So another
question from the US.
They're wondering if there
are any continuous integration
and continuous deployment
options for Flutter apps.
ANDREW BROGDON:
So I think we got
scooped a little bit
by the keynote, right?
So yeah, obviously,
[INAUDIBLE] code.
In the keynote, you saw
their solution for this.
They partnered with this--
WM LELER: This actually
came in after the keynote.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Maybe they wanted
to know what the
whole landscape was.
WM LELER: Yeah, OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: There are more.
For our DevRel
samples, for example,
we use Travis, because it's
free, for open-source projects.
And it works great with Flutter.
There's also
[? Sirius, ?] I believe,
the engineering team
uses for the SDK itself.
They have some really intense
use cases for advanced testing,
and they have found that
fits their particular needs.
But yeah, I mean, the tools
for Flutter, they run on Linux.
They run on the command line.
You can run tests from the
command line very easily.
So they fit very well
into the CI/CD systems.
WM LELER: Right.
But I don't think
that's a problem at all.
And I'm sure there's going
to be additional runs.
One thing that we keep
wanting to point out
is that if there's something you
want that is not available yet,
you can actually go in and
file an issue for Flutter.
ANDREW BROGDON:
That is true, yeah.
It's not only is Flutter
open, in terms of the code
and being able to see it,
it's developed in the open.
So you can actually
go in and take a look
at what the team is working on.
WM LELER: That's right.
You can do it yourself.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
can also do that.
WM LELER: Yeah, that's good.
Well, here's a short one.
How about Dart on
the server side?
ANDREW BROGDON: We kind of
already touched on that.
WM LELER: I know, we
But yes, and you can see that--
I said that question
just because I
wanted to emphasize that Dart
is a general purpose programming
language.
I mean, as you said earlier,
we are focusing on mobile apps
right now, but
there are people who
use Dart, including us, on the
server who use it for web apps,
and so forth.
And you've seen some of
that come out this time,
and I think it's only
going to get better.
And in fact, you're
going to start
seeing it on more and
more devices as well.
In fact, let me
continue with this one.
Here's a question from India.
It says, what are
the new widgets that
are about to come out in
the next Flutter update?
I love that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
Let's touch on this.
Let me go into our--
so the easiest way to
know what the Flutter--
because we get this a lot,
what's the team working on?
What's coming out soon?
And the easiest way is to bypass
us and go straight to the team
itself through GitHub.
So if I go to the main
Flutter repo here,
you'll notice open issues for
feature requests and bug fixes.
You can take a look at those.
But there's also the projects
tab, which the team uses.
So you can see what they're
working on in real time.
The IAP plugin you can see here.
There's a lot of
stuff being done
with Cupertino by Joe and Matt,
the engineers working on that.
Add2App, you can see
the work on that.
It's nearing the
end of its sprint.
And some other things.
You can come in here.
You yourself can come in, just
see what the team is working on
and that might well
answer your question.
If you don't see the thing that
you think is really important,
there's likely an issue
open for it already.
If not, you can create one.
If there is one, go in and
put a comment on it and say,
I'm building with Flutter.
This is important to me because
I need it for this use case.
You can put a thumb up on it.
The team really
loves that feedback.
They really like
getting that and being
able to feel like they're
staying close to what
the community needs.
So it's very valuable for them.
WM LELER: So I'm going
to change gears just
a little bit because
I just noticed
somebody standing nearby.
ANDREW BROGDON: OK.
Who have we got?
WM LELER: Let me read
the question first.
ANDREW BROGDON: All right.
WM LELER: So the
question is, what
is the best way to achieve state
management in a Flutter app?
ANDREW BROGDON: That's Filip.
WM LELER: Well, let me
finish the question.
It says, they're currently
using scoped_model,
but it seems like it is maybe
not the best fit for their app.
So they want to know what's
the right thing to do.
ANDREW BROGDON: Filip,
come and join us.
WM LELER: Yeah, Mr.--
ANDREW BROGDON: You are the
perfect person for this one.
WM LELER: We have Filip here.
FILIP HRACEK: Hey.
ANDREW BROGDON: Fresh from
the keynote, this is Filip,
everybody, one of our
DevRel compatriates.
WM LELER: I think they
already known him.
ANDREW BROGDON: Careful there.
I think you might have kicked
a video cable for a second.
You're going to make all the
guys in the back go nuts.
So careful there.
Actually, I think it
did just disconnect.
WM LELER: So the
question was somebody
who was using
scoped_model, but they
said it's maybe not the right
fit for their app right now.
ANDREW BROGDON: And I
know state management
is a mission of yours.
FILIP HRACEK: Yes.
ANDREW BROGDON:
So how do you get
to scoped_model in the
first place, and then what
might you go on to after that?
FILIP HRACEK: Right.
So yeah, a lot of people are
asking about state management
all the time, and that's
a really good question.
I don't there's one
answer to everyone.
It always depends
on many things.
It depends on the app.
It depends on the team
and previous experience,
and all that.
I think scoped_model
is a really good start,
and for many people,
it is what they need.
Because I think it's pretty
simple to understand.
It gives you all the
things that you want.
It is a little less reactive
than maybe some people
would want.
So a lot of people
will use something
like practice extensions.
Maybe some people are
just super into redox.
Then you have a flood
of redox package build.
So I mean, it depends
on what you want,
what your inputs, are
and stuff like that.
It's not really better.
ANDREW BROGDON:
I think it really
just depends on what are the
patterns you've used before
and enjoy.
I think that is one of
the biggest factors.
If you've used redox in the
past and really loved it,
there's nothing
wrong with redox.
It works great with Flutter.
If you're used to
streams that block things
like that are very good.
FILIP HRACEK: Yes, yes.
And also, I would be
really interested to know
what are the limitations
that this person sees.
Because obviously, there
are things that could--
for example, scoped_model
doesn't really
work that well with
streams, I guess.
ANDREW BROGDON: It rebuilds
widgets in its own way,
rather than providing
streams the way block would,
or something else, right?
FILIP HRACEK: So you
can still use it,
but it kind of feels dirty to
be like listening to a stream
and then notifying listeners.
So anything is possible.
Yeah.
I guess I don't have a
single answer to that.
ANDREW BROGDON: Which is fine.
WM LELER: Do you think
that, in the future,
there might be different
ways of managing state
that we don't even know about?
FILIP HRACEK: Oh yeah, sure.
Sure.
I was actually researching--
I'm always researching.
And last week, I found out that
there is a new thing that's
pretty impressive.
It's not completely baked yet,
but it's always something new.
And I think Flutter
is very young
so it will have a plethora of
different ways to manage state.
And in the end, many people
will tell you state management
is building your app.
I [? assure ?] you
will build your layout,
and stuff like this.
But after that, it's how do I
manage the state of the app?
And so you could go
all the way from just
using state and stateful
widgets, which I don't
recommend, but it can be--
ANDREW BROGDON: You
can go a long way
just with stateful widgets,
instead of rolling your own--
that's not necessarily a bad
way to go for a lot of people
coming, onboarding
themselves with Flutter.
FILIP HRACEK: Yeah, yeah.
I think what we are not
doing a really good job at
is that many people
will just start Flutter.
They will see the
clicking gab where you're
incrementing the counter.
And they think, oh, this is
the way you manage state.
And that's true for
a single widget,
but it's often not
true for the app.
And we're not really
doing much to tell people,
yeah, maybe at least do
something with scoped_model.
WM LELER: Yeah, and I was
actually talking to somebody
earlier and they made a point,
and I think I agree with them,
but I wanted your opinion on it.
They said that Flutter
sort of takes things
far enough that we can actually
invent new types of state
management that are specific
to Flutter and to Dart because
of the characteristics
of Dart being functional
and having streams,
and things like that.
FILIP HRACEK: I was
recently, last week,
talking to a person
who came from Android.
And for many people like that--
for me, when I came to Flutter
first to reactive programming,
it is kind of a
change of mindset.
And so again, we probably should
be more better at explaining.
OK, so for example
it's not a big deal
if you rebuild the whole
app once in a while.
For an Android
person, for example,
like me many years ago--
ANDREW BROGDON: [INAUDIBLE].
FILIP HRACEK: They
would be like, I
hope that you're not recreating
the whole UI from scratch.
But in Flutter, sure, why not?
That's what you do all the time.
ANDREW BROGDON: So we
need to let you go,
but we did have one question
that came up, I think, from--
WM LELER: Oh yes, an
important question.
I almost forgot.
ANDREW BROGDON: Different
people, they have requested.
They want you to
know that they'd
love to see the source
for your timeline app,
if it's at all possible.
FILIP HRACEK: I have to
say it's not just mine,
it's also 2Dimensions'.
And we are going to release
it, but right now it's
a little bit ugly.
So we want to make it
a little nicer first.
It was that last minute
brunch that kind of killed--
WM LELER: So what you're telling
us, it will be available,
you're just not telling us when.
FILIP HRACEK: Oh yeah.
WM LELER: But hopefully soon.
FILIP HRACEK: Yeah, yeah.
Always.
OK.
ANDREW BROGDON: Well,
thank you so much.
Please take the microphone.
Thanks for coming up.
WM LELER: Wow.
Do you have any
Livestream questions?
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah, let's
take a look at the Livestream.
People recommending
their favorite approaches
to state management.
WM LELER: Yeah?
Well, that's good.
We'll have people arguing
for different forms of state
management.
It'll be good.
ANDREW BROGDON: Here's one.
How does Flutter compare
to React Native, which is
something we've heard before.
WM LELER: This is an
excellent question.
So it is important to
compare different products.
But what I worry about
is that sometimes it
turns into sort of an
argument about what's better,
and I don't think
that helps anybody.
Me, personally, I think
React Native was actually
a brilliant thing
for them to do.
They took something that
was made for the web, React,
and they said, hey, we
could take that technology
and apply it to native apps.
And that's a brilliant thing.
Flutter is similar in some ways
in that we're also reactive,
but it's also solving a
slightly different problem.
And I don't expect
React Native to go away.
I wouldn't tell people, oh, if
you're using React Native, just
use Flutter.
They're for different things,
and that's a good thing.
And you were talking
about something
like that the other day.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah.
I mean, this question
comes up a lot.
Obviously, we believe
in Flutter, the SDK,
and what it can do, and that
it can play an important role
in software and helping people.
But it's still just one more
tool in everybody's tool belt,
right?
The fact that
Flutter exists does
it mean that React Native
isn't a good way to make apps.
Obviously, for many,
many developers, it is.
And the same is true of native
development on iOS and Android.
Those things didn't stop
being good ways to build apps,
it's just that Flutter
is another way to do it.
And we think it's
a really good one.
That's about it.
It's two positives
rather than a--
WM LELER: So I've noticed
some other people standing by.
ANDREW BROGDON:
Who's in the corner?
WM LELER: We've got
several questions that
came from people
that, to me, are more
questions about the community.
So for example, one person
asked, when are there
going to be a way to
play sounds in Flutter,
and stuff like that.
ANDREW BROGDON: There is a
way to play sounds in Flutter.
WM LELER: Yeah.
There are plugins in the pub
directory for playing sounds,
and stuff like that.
And as far as I know, they were
all written by third parties.
[INAUDIBLE]
ANDREW BROGDON: Yeah,
open-source development.
And we have one right here.
I can see him.
Come on, Simon.
So some of you
may know this man.
As our next guest, this is
Simon Lightfoot, a London local.
WM LELER: How are you?
SIMON LIGHTFOOT:
I'm good, thank you.
WM LELER: Welcome to London.
SIMON LIGHTFOOT:
Yeah, thank you.
WM LELER: Anyway, we were just
talking about the community.
Can you talk a little bit
about your involvement
with the community?
SIMON LIGHTFOOT: I
mean, we've done a lot
to build the online
conversation that Flutter
invoked in everyone, I think.
WM LELER: Right.
SIMON LIGHTFOOT: We've
started the study group.
We've now got the Flutter
community, Medium.
WM LELER: That's right.
SIMON LIGHTFOOT:
And I mean, everyone
is welcome to publish articles.
We invite everyone
to submit articles
and we'll review
them, edit them,
and make sure they're sent out
on the schedule, which really
helps to make sure that
everyone's getting information
about Flutter that
everyone really
needs to get going immediately.
ANDREW BROGDON: How do
we let the community
know that they shouldn't
ask us when is Google
going to build this or that.
This is going to succeed
if we all work together
on things like that.
SIMON LIGHTFOOT: I
mean, this is it.
I mean, what we've seen--
what we've actually started up
is the Flutter community GitHub
organization.
And what we've done is
any of these projects
that the committee
have built that want
to get owned by the community.
So how is that scenario
of a developer [INAUDIBLE]
maintain their
open-source project.
They start up as
an idea saying, we
want this on our Flutter app.
I made this one app.
Now it's out there.
Who's going to
maintain this product?
People submit PRs,
people submit fixes.
No one's merging them.
So we're here to help.
WM LELER: That's great.
That's an awesome thing to do.
ANDREW BROGDON: I see another
community-- do you mind
if I swap you out for Hillel.
OK, why don't you
pass the baton.
SIMON LIGHTFOOT: I'll
see you guys later.
ANDREW BROGDON: Thank
you so much, Simon.
WM LELER: We have
another community member.
ANDREW BROGDON: Yes.
WM LELER: This is Hillel.
Welcome.
HILLEL COREN: Thank you.
Nice to be here.
What's happening?
ANDREW BROGDON: So
internet, Hillel.
Hillel, internet.
You've probably met before.
HILLEL COREN: Nice
to see you here.
ANDREW BROGDON:
So when I saw you,
I was happy because you were the
guy behind itsallwidgets.com,
which is great.
Can you tell us a
little bit about that?
HILLEL COREN: Sure.
It's All Widgets is a open
site for listing Flutter apps.
Any developer,
anywhere in the world
is free to publish their app.
Doesn't need to be
in the app store.
Doesn't need to be open source.
If you're proud of something you
built and want to showcase it,
you can submit the site.
We're happy to show it.
ANDREW BROGDON: So
we all need a place
to do that occasionally,
to crow about something
that we've built. How
many apps do you have?
HILLEL COREN: So far,
we have about 200.
I mean, that's just in the site.
Obviously, in Flutter, there
are thousands of apps unlisted.
To me, more interesting
than the number,
is the rate of
growth, where it took
a few months to get to 100.
From 100 to 200, it took
about half that time.
ANDREW BROGDON: Oh, wow.
HILLEL COREN: We're seeing
this exponential growth.
WM LELER: So your
half-life is going down.
ANDREW BROGDON: What are some
of the most interesting ones you
have?
I mean, you have 200 apps.
HILLEL COREN: Good question.
So what I find interesting
is when an app is submitted,
it gets shared with
a group of followers.
And every once in
a while, someone
will message me and say, this
app, it can't be Flutter.
Doesn't look like a Flutter app.
And I get nervous,
and I go scrambling,
and I message a developer.
Every time, it turns out,
yeah, it's a Flutter app.
And the thing I think
I've taken from this,
there's no look of Flutter app.
Flutter app can
look like anything.
You're just limited by your
imagination and [INAUDIBLE]
listing of apps, because they're
all completely different.
ANDREW BROGDON: Awesome.
WM LELER: I think we
need a new campaign.
What does a Flutter
app look like?
Anything you want.
HILLEL COREN:
Absolutely, absolutely.
ANDREW BROGDON: You
also did a podcast,
or started a podcast
series recently, right?
HILLEL COREN: That's right.
It's a widget.
Initially, it was
going to be a podcast.
Thomas [INAUDIBLE].
ANDREW BROGDON: It
morphed into a website.
HILLEL COREN: Pretty much.
At the time, Simon Lightfoot
and Scott [INAUDIBLE]
were also working on
their own podcast.
We teamed up, pivoted
to this website.
Now that the site's
kind of finished,
we've had time to go
back to the podcast idea.
So we just started working
on it these past two weeks.
It's been a great response.
ANDREW BROGDON: Who
have you had on so far?
HILLEL COREN: Some
amazing developers.
Marco, Rohan, Omar, GroovinChip.
And if you go to
itsallwidgets.com,
you can see the list.
If you click Podcast
on the top right.
Anyone watching, you're
welcome to be on the podcast.
Just go to the site.
Anyone can send a request
to be interviewed.
And the idea is, the goal
is, just for developers
to share their
Flutter experiences,
to be able to say what
their backgrounds are,
what they're learning, and also
share best practices and tips
and tricks.
ANDREW BROGDON: Cool.
So actually, we've reached
the end of our second block.
So I'm going to ask
you to stay right here.
And one of the things I wanted
to make sure to mention,
the thing that I love
about itsallwidgets.com
is that you can filter based on
whether the app is open source
or not.
HILLEL COREN: Right.
ANDREW BROGDON: And then when
you go in to look at the app,
it will have a link
to the source, which
is the greatest thing ever.
So go look at.
It's itsallwidgets.com.
Look through the apps.
When you see
something like, oh, I
would love to know how they
did that, you can go see how
they did that and it's great.
HILLEL COREN: Actually,
I had one thing.
ANDREW BROGDON: Sure.
HILLEL COREN: I just want to say
that these projects, obviously,
take time and resources.
I'm incredibly lucky to work
with two amazing partners,
[INAUDIBLE] and Dave,
who I love very much.
I'm blessed to
work with you guys.
We work at
[INAUDIBLE] and collab
at the time to work
with these projects.
We're still doing a lot of
Flutter work, these side
projects, but I think we're
going to help the community,
help myself learn more.
It's just been a
great experience.
ANDREW BROGDON: Excellent.
It's a lot of fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]